So what's new Mark, how
is your new job going?
To be honest, I can't
complain. I really love the
company that I am working
for.
My coworkers are all really
friendly and helpful. They really
help me feel welcome.
It's a really energetic and
fun atmosphere.
My boss is hilarious, and
he's really flexible. Really
How so?
He allowed me to come
in when I want and
make my own hours.
I can also leave early.
If I start early, there
is no real dress code
either. I can wear jeans
and a t-shirt if I
want I can even wear
shorts in the summer. Wow
it sounds really cool. I
can't stand wearing a suit
every day which do you
prefer working late for finishing
early? I prefer finishing early,
I really enjoyed the morning.
I love getting up early
and going for a run.
There's nothing like watching the
sunrise while drinking my morning
coffee.
Really. I am opposite. I
love sleeping in.
I am most Alert in
the evenings. I'm a real
night owl.
Well, you know what, they
say, the early bird catches
the worm, you know, you
could be right, maybe I
will try to go to
bed a little earlier tonight.